so this letter is in response to
correspondence send by Dame Carolyn
McCall yesterday to the committee in
which he laid out that there will be an
external investigation led by a
barrister into how the rumors of a
relationship between Phillips Schofield
as star host of this morning and his
much younger colleague were handled by
ITV and the committee is saying that
Dean Carol McCall will answer questions
about safeguarding at ITV as well as
complained handling but the committee
also expanded it saying that it is
important to scrutinize public bodies
it's important to scrutinize the media
and while they are starting with ITV
they said that they will also pose those
questions to other broadcasters such as
the BBC and channel four now just to
remind everyone lady Carolyn McCall has
announced that there will be this
external investigation into what ITV
Executives knew about this rumors of of
a relationship between Phillip Schofield
and his much younger colleague a man who
was only 15 when Phyllis Schofield met
him but with whom Schofield said he only
started a relationship when the man
started working at this morning now we
heard yesterday from ITV that this man
started working on the program when he
was 19 and then moved on to a variety of
other roles within ITV daytime
programming and then finally stopped
working for the broadcaster in 2021 they
were also had pains to point out that
they investigated these rumors of the
affair but found no hard evidence and
that both parties denied involvement as
late as just this month they said they
were badly LED down now clearly this is
leaving some questions about how
efficient ITV has been in trying to get
to the bottom of whether there was an
affair or not and now Dame Carol McCool
will have to face MPS and ask questions
questions about that because this has
turned into more than just rumors and of
how we know that Affair took place and
now it's raising questions whether the
safeguarding procedures at ITV are in
place they were also marred by
accusations of a toxic work environment
by another person who used to work on
the program the former resident doctor
Dr Raj Singh that's also something that
ITV has denied but a crucial question
remains how much exactly ITV Executives
knew about this affair and what they do
did to really get to the bottom of it